July 4th, yesterday, marked the
anniversary of the Battle of Hatton, one
of the most catastrophic defeats in
Christian history inflicted by the
forces of Islam. It was this battle that
led directly to the fall of Crusader
held Jerusalem to Saladin in 1187.
Rather than spoil your barbecue and
fireworks with a July 4th video
commemorating that disaster, I chose to
wait until today, July 5th, to recount a
far lesserk known but equally horrific
event that took place a day after HAD.
It's especially relevant as it centers
on the very subjects of my latest book,
The Two Swords of Christ, The Knights of
the Temple and Hospital. I speak, of
course, of the ritual beheading of these
warrior monks of Christendom. Unlike the
average captured crusader, these knights
were denied ransom. In fact, Saladin
went so far as to ransom any Templar or
hospitaler from their Muslim captives
for 50 dinars a piece simply to ensure
that he could personally witness their
slaughter, sheared like sheep. Before
this grizzly spectacle unfolded, the
magnanimous sultan offered them one
final humiliation, a chance at life in
exchange for conversion. Any knight
willing to utter the words, the shahada,
or Islamic profession of faith, would be
spared and welcomed into the ummah as a
brother. On the evening of July 4th,
just after the battle, Saladin gave this
ultimatum to the roughly 300 templars
and hospitalers he had captured or
bought. He then sent them to a makeshift
desert prison to contemplate their fate,
death or Islam. That night, amid the
howls and jeers of their captives, the
brethren of the temple and hospital did
not panic or plead. Instead, they
reconfirmed their vows to Christ and
prepared for what they saw not as doom,
but martyrdom. As the contemporary
itinerarium peraganorum records, quote,
"A certain Templar named Nicholas had
been so successful in persuading the
rest to undergo death willingly that the
others struggled to go in front of him,
and he only just succeeded in obtaining
the glory of martyrdom first, which was
an honor he very much strove for." 19th
century historian Charles G. Addison
vividly describes our final passion.
quote, "The warlike monks of the temple
and of the hospital, the bravest and
most zealous defenders of the Christian
faith were of all the warriors of the
cross the most obnoxious to zealous
Muslims. Accordingly, on the Christian
Sabbath, at the hour of sunset, the
Muslims were drawn up in battle array.
And at the sound of the holy trumpet,
all the captive knights were led to the
eminence above Tiberius in full view of
the lake of Guanerath. There, as the
last rays of the sun were fading from
the mountaintops, they were called upon
to deny him who had been crucified. To a
man they refused and were all
decapitated in the presence of Saladin.
Both Christian and Muslim chronicers
agree on why Saladin executed the
orders. The itinerarium peraganorum
bluntly states that Saladin quote
decided to have them utterly
exterminated because he knew that they
surpassed all others in battle. Nel Air,
a contemporary Muslim historian, echoed
the same. He wrote, quote, "These two
groups were especially selected for
execution because they had the greatest
valor of all the Franks. He, Saladin,
wrote to his deputy in Damascus,
ordering him to kill all who fell into
his hands. It was Saladin's custom to
execute the Templars and hospitalers
because of their fierce enmity towards
the Muslims and their great courage."
The eyewitness, Ahmed Alin, Saladin's
own court official, records the most
detailed account. After the battle, he
heard Saladin declare, quote, I will
purify the earth of these two filthy
races, for they will certainly not
desist from aggression, and they will
not serve in capacity. So Saladin, he
continues, quote, ordered that they
should be beheaded, choosing to have
them dead rather than in prison. Many of
the Sultan's men, especially the
expounders of Sharia law, begged to be
allowed to kill one of them. They drew
their scimitars, rolled up their
sleeves. Saladan, his face joyful, was
sitting on his throne. Ahmed recounts
how some executioners quote slashed and
cut cleanly unquote, while others made a
mess of things. Eventually, some
faltered, unable to stomach the labor.
But Ahmmed exalts one zealous slayer,
possibly Saladin himself, who quote
killed unbelief or kuf infidelity, to
give life to Islam. I saw the man who
laughed scornfully and slaughtered, who
spoke and acted, how many promises he
fulfilled, how much praise he won, the
eternal rewards he secured with the
blood he shed, the pious works added to
his account with each neck severed by
him. Interestingly, the slaughter of the
knights of the temple and hospital,
which is copiously recorded in both
Christian and Muslim accounts, has for
some odd reason never made it in any of
the big budget Hollywood films that
otherwise revolve around Saladin's
magnanmity. Most notably, Ridley Scott's
2005 Kingdom of Heaven. Meanwhile, this
same incident, being so well documented
and celebrated in Muslim sources,
continues to inspire modern-day jihadist
organizations. The Islamic State of Iraq
and Syria, ISIS, has made several films
intentionally modeled after Saladin's
beheading of the Knights of the Military
Orders. The most notorious being ISIS's
decapitation of 21 Coptic Christians in
Libya 2015.
At any rate, such was the power of the
Knights of the Temple and Hospital, and
such was the hate and fear that Muslims
had for them. In support of Christendom,
they committed themselves to fighting
Islamic aggression. And when the time
came, they choose martyrdom over life.
And yet today, many soft, secularized
Western Christians, virtually
indistinguishable from their atheistic
counterparts, dismiss these men as
fanatics, not true Christians. To learn
more about these forgotten defenders of
the faith, check out my new book, The
Two Swords of Christ: Five Centuries of
War between Islam and the Warrior Monks
of Christendom.
[Music]